trois caps cela fait trente ans
maintenant que donner ce de winter et
son piano sont les premiers à fouler la
scène de la grange de meslay l'accordeur
du festival de piano de la roque
d'anthéron et des fêtes musicales en
touraine qui parcourt le monde entier
aiment retrouver celui unique chaque
année tout à l'heure on entendait
quelqu'un vous dire ici le festival
commence fait plaisir c'est pareil pour
moi je prends un peu les mieux que je
connais bien je connais très bien son
acoustique ses difficultés mais aussi
ses grands océans avantage c'est un
genre un plaisir de venir dans ce temple
même jeu contrôles à répétition la
répétition de de marteau de martonas se
mette le plus vite possible à sa passe
pour démarrer c'est à l'âge de 11 ans en
verre que donner sa découvert le métier
en essayant de réparer un piano que son
père avait ramené à la maison quand
l'accorderez passé il est resté des
heures avec lui plus de 50 ans de
carrière plus tard la maîtrise de la
technique est sans faille
il faut savoir aussi écouter les
pianistes dans mon métier surtout
l'homme est il
heures de concert c'est parti à
à la recherche la recherche du meilleur
son et le d'être meilleures règles pour
le pianiste qui va va faire son concert
il a toujours quelque chose en tête une
image en tête comment ça doit sortir
comment quelles couleurs ils chercher
tout ça et le doute c'est que je
l'assistent sa perceuse s'être cherché
un finalement trouvé
j'aimerais entendre
aujourd'hui de ness de winter est un des
meilleurs accordeur au monde pour les
plus grands pianistes de martha argerich
qui s'arrête où christian zimmermann un
métier de rêve
une chance qu'il souhaite aujourd'hui
partager et transmettre aux plus jeunes